the prosecutor in the trial of kyle
rittenhouse has failed at every stage to
make the case that rittenhouse is guilty
of murder
often his witnesses have made the
defendant's argument for him
so now the prosecutor is complaining
that he's at a disadvantage
because the video evidence is
undercutting his case
your
videos that you have captured of these
incidents that you call riots
they're
very
uh slanted against
the people who are rioting you
characterize them as antifa black lives
matter rioters correct because they are
rioting in the footage yes absolutely
the videos of the events that you call
riots
are really slanted against the people
who are rioting yeah video tends to be
slanted against people who are rioting
if the video of what happened is biased
against the prosecution's case that's
because reality is biased against the
prosecution's case which never should
have been brought to trial in the first
place i'm michael nolis the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from sharon
bisriges who says
i've seen a lot of how does a 17 year
old have an ar-15 but i haven't seen any
how come a convicted felon had a pistol
yeah that's to me the more important
question the people who should be on
trial well i guess two of the people who
were attacking kyle rittenhouse are dead
but that one guy survived why isn't that
guy on trial why isn't that creepy
creepy antifa dude on trial got to
protect yourself folks when you want to
protect yourself i suggest you check out
ring the christmas shopping season is
upon us and i would strongly suggest you
deck the halls walls windows and doors
with the best deals of the year on the
award-winning ring alarm
you know about ring they've been with us
basically since the beginning of this
show
they make this incredible
video doorbell where you can see and
speak to whoever is at your door whether
you're in the house
whether you're at the office maybe
you're on a beach on the other side of
the world well ring will help you keep
an eye on every inch of your house
they've got this award-winning alarm
it's powerful affordable home security
system you can easily install it
yourself
it protects your home from flood freeze
fire as well as protecting your home
from from the baddies it's much much
cheaper than other companies for what
they charge for one month uh those other
expensive companies you can get a whole
year of ring alarm with professional
monitoring right now head on over to
ring.com
knowles that is ring.com
knowles to get a great deal on your ring
security kit today
ring
dot com slash
knowles the videos are not looking good
for the left your honor i'd like
i object i object to playing that video
of what happened that's really not good
for my case i know it's true maybe if
maybe if those videos had gotten out in
the first place you wouldn't have
brought that case and you wouldn't be
humiliating yourself now there are other
videos though beyond the written house
trial that don't look good for the left
one that went viral yesterday a video of
joe biden
calling someone
a negro
you know i've adopted the
attitude of the great
negro at the time pitcher in the negro
leagues went on to become
a great pitcher in the pros into the
major league baseball after jackie
robinson his name was satchel page
there was a fact check i think it was
from mediaite and i said did joe biden
call a guy a negro and they said no no
not really i mean yeah he did but he
didn't mean to and that's what fact
checks are like for democrats now but i
have a different take on this than most
people on the right oh people on the
right yesterday they loved this clip
they were posting it all over joe biden
that racist he called someone a negro oh
look at him could you imagine if trump
oh could you imagine if the shoe were on
the other foot
does anyone actually care that joe biden
used the word negro
does any i'm not saying should they care
she's there a double standard what if
trumpet forget that for a second does
anyone actually care
no
no one does
no black person is offended
no republican who is
pretending to make a big deal out of
this
who is making a big deal and pretending
it is a big deal actually cares and no
democrat cares either about what he said
or about the double standard
this is a completely
impotent political attack
the only way this would be a good
political attack against joe biden
is if democrats cared about their
hypocrisy and double standards but they
don't
so it just doesn't matter by the way the
word negro is not
offensive in and of itself
there are other words that begin with n
that can be offensive but negro was just
the common
ordinary word
for a black person
used by black people used by white
people
used on government forms and then it
became colored person and then it became
black person and then it became
african-american now it's back to
colored person except we have to call it
person of color who knows a negro might
come back into fashion at some point
they just keep changing the word it's
not like
the n-word they're they're actually
different
different words the
to me this kind of politics is such a
waste of time it's such a distraction
it's so lazy
it's not going to help conservatives to
make a big deal out of this attack it's
not going to embarrass democrats the
only thing in this video that does look
looks really bad for joe biden
is that he seems senile he seems senile
he's using the word that was popular
60 years ago
when the last time he remembers anything
and he
is kind of daughtering and he's ah
there's a guy good negro no
no i mean the negro league he was a
player and there was a guy you know he's
played baseball and
[Music]
that's bad that i think is an attack
that might work
on moderates that might
rile up republicans that might
win over independence but playing this
gotcha thing with a i agree it's a
double standard i agree it's hypocrisy
but just
no one actually cares there's a worse
video for joe biden actually another one
came out yesterday where
joe biden's giving a speech about the
inflation crisis the transportation
crisis the fact that gas is going
through the roof and joe biden as if he
were not the president of the united
states as if he were just some passive
observer says good golly folks you ever
think you'd be paying this much for gas
so we got nearly a 20 percent more goods
coming into the country than we did
before the pandemic struck
in 19 days excuse me covet 19 has
changed the way we spend our time and
our money
more products are being delivered than
ever before
that's because people have a little more
breathing room than they did last year
and that's a good thing
but it also means we've got higher
demand for goods at the same time we're
facing disruptions in the supplies to
make those goods
there's a res this is a recipe for
delays and for higher prices and people
are feeling it
they're feeling it do you ever think
you're paying this much for a guy a
gallon of gas
in some parts of california they're
paying four dollars 50 cents a gallon
that's why it's so important we do
everything on our power to stabilize the
supply chain okay first of all just to
tell you how out of touch he is
gas is way higher in california and some
parts of california is pushing up
towards seven bucks
four dollars and fifty cents a gallon is
just the normal price in california
four dollars and fifty cents a gallon in
california in los angeles to san
francisco you don't even batch your
eyelash okay
but second of all
while he's trying to push responsibility
off everywhere else it was because of
the supply chain and it's china and it's
this and it's that and it has nothing to
do with me it has nothing to do with my
energy policies it has nothing to do
with my lockdown policies and it's
nothing to do with me you know the guy
the buck stops here no i have nothing to
do with it he's presenting himself as a
passive observer in politics and this is
bad for him
he thinks this is good for him because
he thinks he can shirk responsibility i
actually think this is a bad bet
because the the big knock on on joe
biden right now
is that he seems really weak he doesn't
seem up to the job
the whole reason
if people voted for him the whole reason
that people voted for them for him is
because he was supposed to be a return
to normal
he's the adult in charge things are
going to get backed he's in command he's
in control but he's he's not in control
he it's like he's
it's like he's the old guy muppet puppet
you know it's just like all right he's
up in the balcony just commenting on the
show
but we don't need a president who's just
commenting on the show we need a guy to
take charge and fix problems and joe
biden is manifestly
incapable of doing that
speaking of cars
there's a new story that
is getting a little attention as a kind
of meme it's just a little weird
headline
people don't see the import of it though
elon musk
elon musk just sold a ton of his tesla
stock
now the way that he did it was he
tweeted out he said
much is made lately of unrealized gains
being a means of tax avoidance so i
propose selling 10 of my tesla stock do
you support this 10 this elon musk is
the tesla guy says i will abide by the
results of this poll whichever way it
goes note i do not take a cash salary or
bonus from anywhere i only have stock
thus the only way for me to pay taxes
personally is to sell stock
right he does it's not as he's a
billionaire but it's not as though he
just keeps money in a bank account the
money is in tesla stock so you can't pay
taxes on it unless you sell that stock
which is going to have huge effects on
the on the price of tesla
so
elon sells 20
billion dollars worth of tesla stock 10
of his holdings and this is ostensibly
because of a twitter poll more people
voted for him to sell it and voted
against him to sell it now
i again have a slightly different take
on this than most other forget just
conservatives most other people here i
think
that elon is
in many ways just trying to cash out or
cash out in part from his overvalued
company i think tesla is very overvalued
it's a cool company it's very impressive
elon musk is a very impressive guy but i
just think if you i mean what is tesla
valued at right now like a trillion
dollars so you know i just i think it's
i think it's too high and so
and i don't think it's worth you know
all of these various car companies put
together and so in a way i think he's
able to cash out of it while making it
seem like a joke while making it seem
like he's not losing faith in the
valuation of the company but but beyond
that he's making a real political point
as well
which is if the biden policy of taxing
unrealized gains
goes into effect
it's going to completely screw up the
stock market and people's investments
because you can't pay cash on unrealized
invest you're gonna have to sell a lot
of stuff it's going to
disturb the economy it's going to upend
the economy even more than joe biden
already has it you're seeing the effects
of that at the gas pump so why don't you
save a little money at the gas pump with
get upside everyone who buys gas needs
to know about this incredible truly
timely advertiser of ours
get upside right now my listeners are
making up to 25 cents for every gallon
of gas every time they fill up just
download the free get upside app in the
app store or google play right now use
promo code knowles k w l e s get a bonus
25 cents per gallon on your first fill
up that is 50 cents cash back do not pay
full price at the pump anymore get cash
back using get upside you get the app
for free you download it use promo code
knowles can wles you'll get up to 50
cents per gallon cashback on your first
tank those who drive a lot are making
two to 300 bucks per month in cash back
there's no catch money gets added right
to your bank account or if you prefer
paypal or an e-gift card to amazon or
other brands it's super simple don't
leave money on the table get the free
get upside app use promo code knowles
canadawles get up to 50 five zero cents
per gallon cashback on your first tank
that is code
knowles
speaking of african-americans
just talking about elon musk now turning
to another prominent african american
the head of
black lives matter in new york city
is threatening riots and bloodshed if
the mayor doesn't give him what he wants
so
speaking of the mayor this head of blm
new york says
if he thinks that they're going to go
back to the old ways of policing then we
are going to take to the streets again
there will be riots there will be fire
and there will be bloodshed because we
believe in defending our people
this he says to the new york daily news
he should be arrested and thrown in
prison just for making that statement
isn't that a threat to free speech no
not really it's very much in keeping
with the american tradition of free
speech there was something i guess there
still is in this country called the
smith act the smith act was the law that
was used in the 40s and 50s to arrest
and prosecute communists and fascists
and anarchists what the smith act did
was said that it is
not legal to advocate for the overthrow
of the government of the united states
and they prosecuted a lot of people then
there was a kind of pullback you know
there was a
weakening of that law and they said no
it's not enough to just advocate the
overthrow it's got you've got to
actually have an imminent way to do that
but the laws are still on the books even
though it doesn't doesn't really get
brought into effect right now and it
wouldn't apply here because the
blm guy is threatening to overthrow the
government of new york city he's not
threatening to overthrow the federal
government so you would need a more
local smith act
but
it would be absolutely just and right
and proper
to put that into place
in in the narrow sense it seems like you
would be curtailing free speech
but in the deeper sense you would be
protecting free speech i don't think our
free speech is really protected here if
the head of black lives matter gets to
threaten to
set things on fire
and cause riots and
have bloodshed right he's threatening to
attack and very likely kill people
to me
i don't feel like i have a great amount
of free speech if i'm going to criticize
black lives matter if i'm going to
advocate for more serious
policing in in the city
now i'm being threatened possibly with
death
he is abusing his right to free speech
to take away my right to free speech my
right to have a nice city my right to
live in peace and and order
so he should go to prison and there
should be a law for that and
conservatives should
defend that sort of thing and we're
gonna have to we're gonna have to change
the the kind of shallow slogany way
we've been talking about free speech and
even policing now we're somehow the
republicans are on the side of letting
the criminals out of prison and the
first step act and prison prison reform
no we have an under-incarceration
problem one of the problems is that the
head of new york black lives matter is
not in prison for saying this kind of
stuff and threatening people and you
just got to put a stop to it
this is the kind of thing that giuliani
did in the 90s back when
last time new york was as bad as it is
right now
giuliani came in and he said we're just
going to arrest the criminals okay
they're going to try this radical crazy
strategy we're going to arrest the
criminals and not let them burn down the
city and kill people and rob people and
guess what happened new york got a lot
better and it persisted for about 20
years persist
i guess 15 years no no about 20 years i
guess persisted through giuliani
persisted through mike bloomberg kind of
preserved it and then
it went to hell in a hand basket
speaking of people who should be in
prison
there is a creepy creepy dude who is in
a viral tic-tock video who is begging to
speak to your children
i want to talk to the kids parents watch
the video and then hand the phone over
to the young kids hi there
um i get asked a lot are you a boy or a
girl and i love that question
and so i wanted to just
tell you
sometimes human beings are more than boy
or girl
sometimes we're something else sometimes
we're both
sometimes um we kind of float
in between and sometimes we're a boy
sometimes we're a girl
because human beings are creatures and
we're wild and exciting
we are wild aren't we and sometimes
we're a little more wild than at other
times and we talked about this yesterday
there was a guy who there was a headline
in the new york post
my husband is gay and we have two kids
and we have a wonderful intimate life
together and
everyone's making fun of this article
and i pointed out what's what's wrong
with it
why is every sexual choice
and sexual identity and sexual desire
choice valid
except for that guys that guy is saying
look i'm a gay guy i have this natural
sexual inclination but i want to have a
family i want to practice my religion i
want to be a part of my culture and my
tradition
and so i'm just going to repress that
part of me and i'm going to cultivate
these other parts of me and i'm not
going to be deceitful about it i'm just
going to i'm just going to do that it
seems like he has a great life and they
have a nice time together and the woman
acknowledges she says physical
attraction is not obviously it's not the
bedrock of our relationship but there is
something actually deeper than that and
i'm kind of okay with that i actually
like that physical attraction is not the
basis of our relationship because looks
are going to fade but there's something
deeper there
when i watch that creepy guy on the tick
tock video trying to talk to your kids
about how sex isn't real and you know
boys should wear lipstick and be fluid
and whatever
it reminds me
repression is a good thing
repression is a really good thing it
gets a real bad rap these days but
repression is good we all have
inclinations and things that are a
little weird about us that we ought to
repress every single one of us does
and some of us i guess a little more
than others if you're a guy who thinks
that he's a woman and wants to dress up
in all that glitter paint and talk to a
bunch of kids then you've got a lot of
things that you ought to repress but you
should repress them the reason that it
gets a bad rap is because we're still in
the thrall of sigmund freud we're still
in the thrall of of the era of
psychology that that thought the human
brain resembled a steam engine
that thought that the way our desires
and our mind works is that we have these
natural desires there's no way to change
them ever and so if we don't let them
out if we don't blow off a little steam
we're gonna go crazy and explode but
that's not actually how the mind and
desire work
okay different eras it's interesting
different eras
seem to map the their vision of how the
mind works on the prevailing technology
at the time
so these days we're beginning to think
of the mind as a computer because what's
the big technology of our time is the
computer before that it was the steam
engine before that it was the printing
press this idea of making impressions
imprinting on your mind
but actually the real way the mind and
desire work are sort of the opposite of
the steam engine freud view
the real way it works is
that virtue and vice are habits so
you'll know you'll know this if if
you've ever dealt with an
addiction the more you give in to your
addiction
the less control you have over it if
you're a drinker the more you drink the
harder it is not to take that drink
it's true of sex it's true of gluttony
it's true of all of these things
and the more you repress those things
if you're a recovering alcoholic
the further away you get from those
first hundred days 200 days two years
five years the easier it becomes because
virtue and vice are habits so i'm not
saying that that guy is obviously a very
confused guy and he's got a lot of
problems if he wants to be talking to
kids about how he's really a girl but
but
it does actually get a little bit easier
it's uh it's not good for him to be
indulging this craziness it's not good
for him it's not good for society it's
not good for the kids he's trying to
talk to it's not good for anybody
it's not good for our society's grasp on
reality
and so
if we encourage that behavior we're
going to get more of it it's going to be
harder not to do that if we discourage
that and we encourage that that
naughty little word the r word
repression
actually i think we'll all probably get
along a little better i know it's a very
unpopular view these days but it is
obviously correct you know i hate to say
i told you so
but
i told you so and uh jordan peterson the
great jordan peterson
speaking of psychology right this is one
of the most prominent psychologists in
the world he just exploded with our
other buddy dave rubin because
the
corporate just got pulled out from under
him he was told
get the fauciauchi and life is going to
go back to normal and it turns out
that's not what happened
canadians who are unvaccinated now
cannot leave the country
like what the hell why why is that and
i'm look i got vaccinated and people
took me to task for that and i thought
all right i'll get the damn vaccine
here's the deal guys i'll get the
vaccine you
leave me alone
and did that work no
so stupid me
you know that's how i feel about it
it's like well now i have to get tested
for kovid when i come back into canada i
have to get tested before i leave canada
now you know that might be the latter
issue that's an issue with the americans
and and so that's outside of the
canadian purview but the restrictions to
get back into canada are even more
stringent it's like why to get the
vaccine then if you're not going to
leave me alone
no more mr nice canadian
there's something there's something
really funny about hearing this urbane
very serious very well-respected public
intellectual
canadian guy just because canadians are
so nice right just using expletives what
happened i thought i was able to no they
were never they were never going to do
it they were never going to
let up on these restrictions
jordan peterson very intelligent guy and
sometimes you know especially professors
they're so intelligent they're so in the
abstract they miss these very practical
things
the left promised you wear the mask take
the jab lock down for 15 days and then
here's that little carrot right at the
end of the stick and we'll let you get
back to normal
it wasn't going to help you get back to
normal it was going to make it less and
less likely the more you give in the
more you give in to them the less and
less likely it is that they will ever
let you get back
to normal that's the way power works
in society
you know
one thing that's very powerful
blue light from your screens
okay and
sometimes it can cause eye strain it can
cause anxiety can cause headaches
you're going to want to check out blue
blocks i almost never look at a screen
anymore with blue light coming out of it
okay and i haven't for years a few years
ago but more than a few years ago now a
friend of mine turned me on to this
problem when you look at screens with
blue light coming out it can just cause
eye strain cause headaches it can and
you can notice it the minute that you
block out that blue light
gets a little bit easier on your eyes
this is why i love the blue blocks blue
light computer glasses other brands do
not compare to the quality you get from
blue blocks glasses they've got stylish
frames that have been featured in gq and
vogue unlike other blue light glass
companies b-l-u-b-l
blue blocks uses science-backed
technology tested to ensure that they
work
they're they're really terrific they
come in non-prescription prescription
and reading options glasses for every
need blue light for helping with digital
eye strain summer glow for helping with
low mood and migraines and sleep plus
for improving your sleep go check it out
right now they ship worldwide in rapid
time easy returns and exchanges go to
blueblocks dot com slash knowles use
coupon code knowles to save twenty
percent
b l u b l o x dot com slash knowles use
coupon code knowles to save 20
there are
new ways that the ruling class is going
to control you
right there are new ways of
interconnection
what jordan peterson
was upset about
is he he did the rules they made a deal
right they made a deal with him they
said you get the shot and then you can
go back to normal and then they yanked
the you can go back to normal thing he
says leave me alone and i think a lot of
people
feel that way that resonates with a lot
of people leave me alone
right that that's kind of the the
libertarian mantra just leave me alone
you do you you do whatever you want and
just leave me alone and the problem is
you you can't be left alone
you can't be left alone in modern
society in society before modern society
at all times the leave me alone you do
you thing has never worked i think we
have this revisionist idea that america
was all about purely rugged
individualism and people getting to do
whatever they want that is just not true
okay
even when we had a very weak federal
government so you know the states could
do what they wanted the communities
could do what they want
all of those places were pretty
robustly policed
this nation was founded when a bunch of
religious zealots came over on the
mayflower
because they didn't feel at home in
england where they weren't allowed to
practice they're extremely authoritarian
religion they're extremely illiberal
authoritarian
rigid community
and then some people which would leave
that community
and very often when they would leave the
community whether it was at plymouth or
the massachusetts bay colony they would
leave to go found other
equally rigid authoritarian communities
okay they're blue laws on the books laws
against
sexual behavior tons of laws against
sexual behavior some of which were
punishable by death laws against
drinking laws against dancing laws
against
all sorts of things
okay and
you might say well why does anyone care
about what my personal behavior is
because that's how society works right
that's politics is just what we all do
together and maybe the different local
communities have relative autonomy
compared to the other ones but the idea
that the individual just gets to choose
to do whatever he wants is a very very
modern idea it's come up in the last 50
years or so and even then the people who
were pushing it on the left didn't let
that last for long now they are imposing
rules that are just as authoritarian
just as rigid just as a liberal
as the ones before them they just happen
to be along different standards along
different sort of lines
and you're seeing that now in a very
silly way on peloton
peloton you know is the electric bike
company it got kind of popular during
during covid but it
i'd always heard it had these left wing
leanings
so i thought this is why i didn't get a
peloton i was thinking about getting a
peloton i thought i don't know i hear
it's fine or whatever but i said i heard
it's kind of lib i heard it's kind of
like a woke company
you know i hate to say i told you so i
was right
i was right so my producer
the
great ben davies texts me the other day
he says
michael i was using this exercise bike
this peloton
and
i typed in the hashtag let's go brandon
so all the people who were on the
hashtag let's go brandon could work out
together it was kind of funny we're
having a good time the next day i tried
to do it it was gone you couldn't you
couldn't log into it peloton
banned the hashtag
let's go brandon so i thought maybe it's
just your bike ben i don't know then we
start hearing it from other people then
people start sending the tip into the
daily wire
you can't do it and it seems like such a
minor thing
but this is how the left wins
all these little minor things
you suppress the let's go brandon
hashtag on the exercise bike
which is why by the way that's why i
would recommend checking out the echelon
exercise bike rather than the peloton
echelon a little more open okay a little
less
rigid and ideological and so i would you
know just these are just my preferences
okay but the peloton they say okay
let's go brain that's not gonna work or
facebook says no you can't post the
hunter biden laptop story or twitter
says no you can't post this thing that's
critical of say dr vauchy or the cdc and
oh it's just and you can't say this
thing in the classroom and oh this and
this and it's death by a thousand cuts
to say nothing of the huge laws and the
huge enforcement mechanisms of the
federal government even just at the
cultural level
all these little tiny things they all
come in together
to shape what we're allowed to say
the things we're allowed to advocate the
blm guy you know blm that the terror
wing of the democrat party
blm comes out and says if you
push against the stuff that we want
we're going to kill you that's what he's
saying we're going to we're going to
burn your place down we're going to kill
you
all these little things that shape
behavior
stop you
stop you from saying and doing what you
want living in the kind of society you
want
now
what is that going to mean into the
future i something tells me joe biden is
not long for this political world at
least he's just he's very senile he's
obviously not up to the job his approval
rating is in the gutter it's about 38
but the problem is kamala's approval
rating is extremely low as well kamala's
approval rating is actually lower it's
plunged according to usa today in
suffolk university to 28
this is the lowest rating i think ever
recorded for a vice president dick
cheney
was close he was at 30 but that was at
the very end of the bush administration
that was in that was in 2007 after he
shot a guy in the face
and everyone blamed him for everything
the iraq war and all that stuff
kamala's already significantly lower
significantly lower than joe biden even
lower than dick cheney's that's really
bad news for democrats in 2024
what's going to happen to them they're
below water on every single poll and why
is it why is kamala's approval rating so
low there was a clip yesterday that i
think just perfectly encapsulated why
people find kamala hair is so
insufferable where she is at some event
explaining the scientific method to
scientists
one of the things i think people in
politics
and government
should really
take from the approach of scientists
scientists operate
with a hypothesis
i love that a hypothesis it's well
thought out it's well planned they start
out with a hypothesis and then they test
it out
knowing invariably you're trying
something for the first time there will
be glitches there will be mistakes
then everyone gets together no one gets
beat up about it
you analyze it what went wrong
reevaluate update the hypothesis and
start again
this woman raises vacuity to a high art
form i did not know it was possible for
something to be so
empty of substance that speaking of
science this this must have been
kamala harris must have been developed
at cern in the cern laboratory i mean
this is we talk about like black holes
as sort of just the absence of
everything that's pulling all of this
matter in
has kamala harris ever had one
substantive thought
scientists have hypotheses i love that
it's so disingenuous it's so empty
ain't nobody gonna vote for that okay no
that's why she was the first person out
in the democrat primary in 2024. bad
news for them good news for us when it
comes to joe biden's vaccine mandate
the daily wire is not backing down we
filed our lawsuit against the
unconstitutional mandates last week
we're already seeing results the fifth
circuit court of appeals issued a
temporary stay over the weekend
preventing joe biden's vaccine mandate
from going into effect this is an urgent
matter and your medical freedom depends
on it if you want to support the fight
to make your personal medical decisions
without government interference sign our
petition against joe biden's mandate
hundreds of thousands of americans have
already signed the petition in just a
few days we need many more people to
stand with us to reach our goal so
please head on over to dailywire.com do
not comply to sign the petition today
also got to tell you
if i have a bag under my eyes today it's
because i was out last night
with andrew clavin we went and had
dinner we went and had a cigar we went
and had a drink or two
we have a lot to celebrate with drew his
new novel when christmas comes is
jumping up the charts actually
i think the only reason it stalled out a
little on the charts is they ran out of
books the publisher sold all the books
they had they said print the books we
got to reprint these books
because it's selling like hotcakes it's
a tremendous book
uh dean koontz the great dean coons
described it as a wonderful gripping and
a pure delight the book centers around
the story of a sleuthing english teacher
who will need a christmas miracle to
prove a condemned man innocent
it's a seasonal tale of tradition family
and of course murder its chilling twists
are best experienced curled up beside a
burning yule log
go pick up a copy for yourself or your
thrill-seeking loved ones at amazon or
anywhere you buy books today just in
time for christmas it's really terrific
drew is simply peerless as far as
fiction writers go today wonderful
wonderful christmas read go check it out
we'll be right back with the mailbag
welcome back to my favorite time of the
week the mailbag first question from
ethan dear michael thought experiment
for you
would it be right to make everyone take
the vaccine if it meant overturning roe
v wade the left claims bodily autonomy
to cover abortions and some on the right
claim bodily autonomy in resistance to
the vaccine mandate leftists then say
that their bodily autonomy is
inconsequential because the disease
poses an imminent threat to the lives of
others by their own logic abortion
always poses an imminent threat to the
life of another so what if we offered
them a deal overturn roe and every
pro-lifer who hasn't taken the vaccine
will get fully vaxxed would you accept
this deal
of course of course i would say
i wouldn't hesitate one nanosecond to
take that deal
but it's because conservatives are
falling into a little bit of a trap here
we're we're saying to the the left and
now in the vaccine uh my body my choice
libs whatever happened to my body my
choice but don't forget we don't
actually believe my body my choice yes
we're using that stupid line against the
left to prove their hypocrisy but we
don't actually believe that
we don't
obviously not on abortion where it's
another body right so you're not even
just focusing on your own body you're
focusing on the body of the baby but
even beyond that we don't believe that
we have the right to do whatever we want
at any time to our bodies that's why we
have laws against drugs that's how why
we have laws against suicide that's why
we have laws against all sorts of things
and all sorts of abuses that we can make
to our bodies you don't actually have
the right to that a lot of conservatives
these days i've noticed have this line
they'll say i look i'm pro-vaccine but
anti-mandate
and i'm sort of the opposite i'm kind of
anti-vaccine and pro-mandate
we have a legal basis for vaccine
mandates in this country goes back to
the case in 1905 it's a lot of it a lot
of hay has been made over it during this
debate which establishes the precedent
that the government
in some cases does have the right
during an epidemic
to mandate a vaccine and if you don't
get the vaccine they at least have the
right to fine you for doing that
that we established that over 100 years
ago
we talk about george washington
requiring inoculations against smallpox
for the continental army in 1777.
that was before the constitution fair
enough but still that we have a lot of
precedent for this in the country
and my issue isn't with vaccines
generally my issue is with this vaccine
for this virus
if there were a really super-duper
dangerous virus that had a an infection
fatality rate
above
0.5 percent or something you know which
in this case it's not just is it 0.5 for
the coronavirus but for the vast
majority of people
it's like point zero
zero
three percent or point zero zero five
percent or depending on your age group
for some people it's point zero zero one
percent so i just think if
if we had a 30 fatality rate from this
virus
yeah i'd be all i'd be fine with vaccine
mandates of course if this were a really
super duper dangerous virus for whole
swats of people yeah sure
i think we would all agree with that if
there were taken to its extreme let's
say there were a virus going around that
was that killed 90 of people that got it
would you support a vaccine mandate of
course you would
especially if the vaccine
had some precedent we're not a new
vaccine technology had gone had some
long-term data even yeah of course you
would
but that's just not the case here
and so now if you're asking me okay mike
i actually don't think the vaccine poses
a huge threat to people but there are
risks and it has killed people and there
have been side effects and even the cdc
and the fda acknowledged that and for
most people the viruses poses such a low
risk to them that i just don't see the
reason for a lot of people to get the
vaccine but if you told me michael
if we're going to make all the
pro-lifers take the fauchiochi and then
we get rid of abortion in america cool
sign me up i can't give me give me five
jabs i don't care if you're gonna end
abortion great love it from glenn dear
austere religious podcaster i've been
listening to all of the shows for
several years now i recently joined to
help support the legal battle against
the biden vaccine mandate thank you very
much i really appreciate that now i can
finally get the answer to this question
that has been on my mind since i started
listening
why does everyone the daily wire pretend
to hate you is it a harvard yale rivalry
between you and ben is ben jealous that
your book without words was wildly
successful or is it the go-to excuse of
our day and age that everyone is racist
against your italian heritage to quote
silvio dante from the sopranos this is
anti-italian discrimination
is what it is
it also goes back
to yes it does have something i don't
think it has to do with yellow harvard i
think it does go back to the blank book
because ben was upset that i sold more
blank books than he had sold books with
words ben had spent a long time writing
all these books and words and there were
very you know lots of different books
and he works very very hard and then i
just had this blank book and it sold
about a gazillion copies so it went back
to that it also went back we had an
election bet and uh you know back when
everyone all the odds were giving
hillary clinton 99 chance that she was
going to win the race
ben and i engaged in an election bet
and it was 100 bet on trump and ben was
so confident he said i'll give you odds
i'll give you four to one odds it's a
four to one odds all right i'll risk 100
bucks for 41 odds and then
the magic happened and then contrary to
all of the polls donald trump won
so i think it goes back to that but but
at the the most basic level yeah it's
anti-italian discrimination from shelby
hi michael i have a dilemma my aunt was
recently diagnosed with cancer
i'm sorry to hear that we'll have to
undergo chemotherapy soon
sadly it's not curable and we likely
don't have much time left with her i'm
considering the vaccine just so that i
may see her and spend some final time
with her as we've been very close my
entire life i'm a young healthy woman
at 25 and wouldn't take the vaccine
otherwise if you had a loved one in this
scenario would you take the vaccine any
other advice thanks i'm a huge fan of
the show
well i just don't
i'm very sorry to hear about your
situation i don't see why you need to
take the vaccine
and you're
not to be too morbid about it but you're
telling me your your aunt is on the
brink of death so you i don't think you
really need to worry about
killing her right you're saying she's
already about to die
uh
even if you have the vaccine let's not
forget that
the vaccine does not totally prevent
the contracting or transmitting the
coronavirus the cdc admitted that at the
end of july
so
i don't i i just don't see why maybe
some of your family members want you to
but who cares what they think i mean
it's really more you're talking about
the concern for your aunt i guess if
it's the issue that you can't get into
the hospital or you can't get into the
hospice
without
without proof of vaccination that
i i would be surprised if that were the
case but if that is the case
and you're saying michael should i take
the vaccine to see my loved one or even
you're asking me would i do that would i
would i take the vaccine to go see my
dying loved one yeah 100
100
it would be a prudence i i don't i don't
like the vaccine
i i don't think it's particularly
necessary i i don't like the vaccine
being pushed to everybody i i do think
that for some people you know that they
can make a good prudential choice to do
it if you're very old if you're very
unhealthy but yeah i don't i don't like
that idea i don't think the risk of
coronavirus is particularly high uh but
still
it's my loved one
okay i also don't think the risk of
dying from the vaccine is all
particularly high either so i just i
would make a prudential judgment in that
way and i think you know i don't think
there would be anything unprincipled or
hypocritical about you doing that
but i also don't see
why necessarily you would need to do
that to see your your aunt but you know
we can we can pray for you very sorry to
hear about your situation from nick
oh no
hi michael me again this is nick this is
the famous nick in the past few months
i've noticed a large uptick in my dms
from women
both looking to take their title shot at
the champ and others who want me to join
some kind of pyramid scheme now you do i
guess you do get a lot of those on
instagram from going through the
comments after your shows i believe this
is because i've become quite popular
with some of your groupies yeah i bet
that's true however i'm afraid of
getting portnoyed
if one of these babes makes good on her
promises and then regrets it when i
inevitably don't agree to meet her
parents for thanksgiving as long as they
are over 18 on insta am i good or since
now i'm the most famous person on your
show
do i need to carry this power more
responsibly
sincerely with great power comes great
responsibility and also options
well nick as
is often the case you've hit on a good
point which is um
if i guess you know you probably are the
most famous person on this show at this
point um
if you're
if you like dave portnoy or have a lot
of attention and
people have found you and they're
messaging you and it's these young
impressionable girls i also don't know
how old you are nick i'm gonna hope that
you're just like in your 20s or
something and you're not in your 40s or
older
which would make it the situation even
worse
should you just should you use these
girls for sex is what you're saying
should i use these girls for sex
even if it's consensual even if they are
literally asking for it
no
no nick get it through your head it's
not just you i actually
i'm glad the question came up because
this is a common issue in our culture
today
we are made to believe today that that
consent is everything
as long as two people consent to
something it's totally fine there was
some case in germany a while ago where
someone posted on craigslist and asked
for someone to kill and eat him
it was like his fetish or something he
wanted to and it was consensual wasn't
it but it's still wrong it's still
that's a great extreme of this it's
still wrong to abuse your power it's
still wrong
to use women just for sex
it's still it's still wrong to do those
things
it there is no and i you know the
portnoy situation really brings this up
everyone knows who dave portnoy is no
one is going in with any illusions in
one of the cases with portland a girl
literally asked for him to simulate a
rape and then she would she regretted it
afterwards she said oh my gosh it was so
bad i felt like i was being raped that's
literally what you asked for and you got
what you asked for and you realize that
your desires were disordered and that's
wrong and it's bad for the person who's
abusing the power and it's obviously
wrong for the person who is being
used here
this is a point i wanted to make
yesterday
when we talk about virtue advice when we
talk about doing the right thing or you
know doing the wrong thing
we we think of it as a way of just
resisting temptation we have these
desires and we just have to resist the
temptation
or you know we need to turn our eyes up
and do the good thing
yes you do have to do that you have to
turn your intellect toward what is good
toward god right you need to turn your
conscious will toward god
but you also want to order your desires
toward god you can actually change your
desires right to use that case of the
of the alcoholic
when the alcoholic puts his head on his
pillow well he probably won't think
about very much if he's super drunk but
if he let's say he's jonesing for a uh
whiskey
his mind will just only be thinking
about whiskey the addict is only
thinking about the thing that he
is addicted to
over time the more you break away from
that you discipline your will you disapp
you discipline your your ability to
resist these things but you also reorder
your desires so that when you put your
head on your pillow at night you're
thinking about something else you're
thinking about maybe you're thinking
about your family maybe you're thinking
about
your soul maybe you're thinking about
god maybe you're thinking about a nice
beach that you visited when you were a
kid maybe whatever you're thinking of
your desires will actually be turned in
a different way as well and so this is
why it's very bad for the person abusing
the power and also for the for the girl
who's being abused don't
do it nick settle down didn't i tell you
two months ago or something to go just
get married get married
the girl who dm's you just dm or right
back said do you want to get married and
then get married and be done with it
from john
i've been following the written house
case and what is most interesting to me
is the potential lawsuits if kyle is
found innocent
i've seen dozens of news outlets and
even campaign videos calling kyle
everything from a murderer to a white
supremacist do you think kyle
will be the next nick sandman if he is
acquitted thanks he has got to get
acquitted first and yes if you've been
watching the trial everyone can see this
was obviously self-defense the kid
didn't take a bad shot
but
this is very politicized we live in an
age where not everything i mean
all ages are such that not everything is
fair and in this age the whole deck is
stacked against
this kid so he's got to get acquitted
first if he gets acquitted yeah i think
he should go the nick sandman route and
i hope he becomes a trillionaire next
question from quade mr knowles how do
you respond to the idea that christians
should not fight progressive culture
because of god's sovereignty god's plan
will be enacted ultimately but does that
not mean that we should fight for a
moral society well yes god is god is
sovereign god you know is the maker of
heaven and earth and is deeply involved
in every aspect of the creation
constantly and he sustains us we have
free will
and we have the ability to cooperate
with god's grace or to turn away from
god
and we are incarnate beings and we are
called to politics because we're called
to live together because we're not just
isolated atoms floating free in the
world
okay we are
living together the the authority is
legitimate right god god grants that
there will be political authority the
authority doesn't carry the sword in
vain as saint paul writes in the letter
to the romans and so we we do have a
political responsibility here and we
have a responsibility to use our free
will in cooperation with god's grace we
don't have the right to abuse our free
will to turn away from god people do
that but that's wrong and it violates in
some cases the civil law and it
certainly violates the moral law we have
an obligation and a duty to cooperate
with god's grace last question from tom
michael i was catching up on the daily
wire shows you had an interesting
observation that the american
conservative movement continues and has
long been led by catholics buckley
russell kirk phyllis schlafly brent
bozell to continue with this uh thought
today we've got robbie george ryan
anderson so rabbi mari ranesh panuru
sheriff gerges to name a few do you
think today's conservative movement is
essentially a vehicle to bring everyone
home to the catholic church well i'm you
might be getting it in the opposite
direction it'd be great you know i'm
catholic i'd like for everyone to be
catholic but i think
the reason that catholics
historically just always play an
outside's role in conservative movements
is because the catholic church is the
conservative institution
it's the only institution in the west
that made it from antiquity to modernity
all of the other institutions even some
of the ones that we like are products in
many ways of modernity and so ultimately
they can't be
conservative and and that's just a fact
and maybe it tells you something about
the religion maybe tells you something
about politics
i don't know that's that's that's for
you to decide but but uh
we can we can all pray we can pray for
one another i'm michael noel's the
michael knull show see you on monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boury our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021 hey
everybody this is andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin